Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and in my last
couple of Doctor Who videos I asked you all
to submit questions about the new character
Danny Pink and Series 8, so I picked 10 of
them to answer in this video with one bonus
question.
There’s also been a lot of talk about a
new Master that ties in with the new Danny
Pink character, so I tried to pick a couple
of those questions.
I’ve also got a big announcement, I’m
going to be changing my youtube avatar soon.
It’s going to probably be a version of this
Sherlock Chibi with my eye color.
You can let me know whether you like that
idea or think it’s terrible.
It will still be on the blue background like
it is now but it probably won’t have the
text.
I don’t know when exactly it’s going to
be finished.
But I’ll let you know who the artist is
when it’s done so you can see her other
fandom chibis.
I’m also going to be doing a video for all
the rumored episode titles and details for
series 8.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
Even if it turns out to not be true it’s
still a good jumping off point for talking
about the stories we want to see during series
8.
Now, time to answer some questions, Number
1 - Cure 9269 says what about Steven John
Shepherd from East Enders?
He even grew a beard and said he’s working
on something secret.
So Steven said he was working on something
secret and then took this picture of himself
with a Classic Who Master Beard on the South
Whales Coastline, Doctor Who was actually
filming Series 8 near that area around the
time that picture was taken.
So the Mirror is reporting that he could have
been filming scenes with Doctor Who as The
Master.
It’s a long shot and this is the only evidence
we have, so let’s add him to the top 5 potential
new Masters.
Question 2 - Incroyable Dalek asks Will Capaldis
screwdriver be the one that river song will
give him?
I don’t think so, River’s Screwdriver
from Silence in the Library Forest of the
Dead was featured in the Series 6 short Last
Night.
I think Capaldi will get a new one.
I’m sure they’ll use the moment to tell
some more regeneration jokes, but we have
no idea what it will look like.
Hopefully they’ll reveal an image of it
while they’re still filming or at least
at Comic Con this summer.
Question 3 - Kitty Kerosene says What if the
Danny Pink character is a Red Herring?
So good comment, you’re talking about Moffat
using the Danny Pink persona as a mask for
something more sinister.
Like Samuel Anderson is playing another character
pretending to be Danny Pink.
There was a recent blog post on Katerborous
that claims Danny Pink may be the new Master.
I think it would be an interesting twist,
a teacher at a very famous School in the Doctor
Who Universe, one that the current companion
just happens to work at, turns out to secretly
be The Master.
Derek Jacobi’s Master stored his true self
in the pocket watch, so if Danny Pink pulls
one out we can all “oh shit” high five
each other.
Question 4 - JER asks will series 8 will have
episode pairs like series 1-6 or none like
series 7?
No, I think generally people were upset that
they had to wait so long to get the second
half of series 7 and it seems like the BBC
listened.
Moffat has said that the season will air all
the episodes in consecutive weeks.
There hasn’t been an official announcement
about the Christmas Special.
But I think we should expect one.
Question 5 - Amelia Pond asks Do you think
danny may be some companion's relatives/ son
and might he be the new mickey smith?﻿
No, I think given the level of rumors that
he is secretly someone else, he’s not biologically
related to any of the other characters.
If he is the Master or just someone bad, then
I’m sure there will be some implied shared
history with The Doctor.
In all likelihood, he just knows Clara like
people who work together get to know each
other.
Question 6 - Khiya Hillyard asks There's a
speculation going around that capaldi's only
going to be around for one series.
What do you think?
His contract is currently only for series
8.
That doesn’t mean he’ll only do one series.
He has been a life long fan of Doctor Who,
so he does have a lot of reverence for the
role.
Most of the time actors leave because they
get tired creatively or have better opportunities
elsewhere.
Like Matt Smith and Karen Gillan’s movie
careers taking off in Hollywood.
If Capaldi does only stay for one series it
would present some interesting challenges
to the story.
How would the finale work and then wouldn’t
they have to do another Christmas Special
regeneration like last year.
Also, casting new Doctors can be difficult.
They announced Capaldi before the 50th Anniversary
and I think they cast him within a couple
months of Matt Smith announcing he was leaving.
So if Capaldi ends up leaving, they would
have to announce it pretty soon.
Question 7 - crazybrownie101 asks Since series
8 is supposed to be like classic who, do you
think they will combine the seriousness of
that and the funniness of the modern series
together?
Yes absolutely, if you’ve seen some of the
behind the scenes images from the first episode
you can see Capaldi making funny faces, so
there will definitely be some awkward humor
at first.
Him just getting used to his new self and
Clara getting used to him.
The first couple of episodes are directed
by Ben Wheatley, who has done a lot of classic
70s Horror stuff.
So I think his episodes will be serious, just
given that he’s a horror afficionado.
The rest of the season remains to be seen
though.
When I do my video breaking down all the episode
rumors, I’ll try to talk about each of the
directors and how their previous episodes
might inform what the tone of the new stuff
will be.
Question 8 - minembo asks Do you know if any
old companions excluding river,amy, and Rory
are coming back?﻿
Outside of the ones you mentioned no, it’s
possible that since both Clara and a new Character
work at Coal Hill School that there will be
a few classic companion cameos.
But if they do appear, it would probably be
as different characters than they originally
played.
Question 9 - BB Plays games asks Do you think
in series 8, Capaldi's doctor will meet any
of his previous selves trying to find Gallifrey?
No, but a lot of people are taking the quote
from Tom Baker during the 50th Anniversary
to mean that.
I think his comment about revisiting old faces
just means that there will be more classic
doctors in the next Anniversary Special.
Which will probably happen in 5 years.
I don’t think they’ll wait a full 10 years
to do another one.
5 years is a long time in television.
Question 10 - Lotsafuntano asks When River
Song first told Doc #10 his name, to prove
she was trustworthy, she apologized and looked
so terribly sad.
When she whispered it to him, he looked horrified.
He says, "There is only one reason I would
tell you my name."
From the look on his face the reason is, obviously,
a horrifying reason.
Have there been any theories as to what this
reason will be?
My first thought after seeing it was that
in the future the Doctor told her his name
as he lay dying.
As in his final death.
Since that’s such an abstract concept, like
the Valeyard.
I don’t think Doctor Who the series will
ever show the Doctor’s final death.
Hopefully the show runs forever, but I think
logically they would end it in a way that
allows the Doctor to continue even if he’s
not on TV anymore.
The story would just continue in book stories
and Big Finish audio dramas.
That’s just my interpretation of that scene
though.
Bonus Question - This isn’t really a question
but it’s really cool.
commenter Husk JV was actually at the Newcastle
comic con where Sylvester McCoy said he knew
who the next Master was.
So I’m just going to read their comment
in full.
And they say, “I was actually there at Newcastle
Film and Comic Con when Sylvester McCoy told
us, it was odd that it went out so quickly
though - there was only about 70 of us watching
the talk (masquerade was on :s), and I saw
only one pull their phone out (assuming for
twitter or something.)
The funny thing was everyone just looked at
each other, then back to Sylvester again.﻿”
Based on your comment it’s hard to tell
if McCoy was just joking, he is super funny
in real life.
I think he would be pulling some legs by saying
he knew who the Master was.
There’s really no way to know who knows
all of the actors coming and going for meetings
about potential roles even the smaller ones.
There were rumors that people knew the new
Doctor was Peter Capaldi was the new Doctor
within days of Matt Smith announcing he was
leaving.
I think it’s just important to keep in mind
that things change all the time.
Matt Smith announced he was doing series 8
in 2012 and changed his mind after Series
7 finished airing.
So still lot’s to talk about.
Thanks so much for submitting questions, this
was a ton of fun as always.
Like I said, my next Doctor Who video will
probably be a breakdown of everything we know
about the Series 8 episodes.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
I’ll try to post that either this weekend
or early next week.
Right now click here to learn all about Danny
Pink the new character and click here for
my top 10 picks for new Time Lords.
Not new Doctors, just new Time Lords.
Thanks so much for watching, see you guys
tonight.
High Fives!